vous auriez quoi en vous si vous aviez
une baguette magique
interview simple un art vivo
[Musique]
vous pensez à quoi là je me dis merde
pourquoi parce que je pensais échapper à
ce genre de trucs
vous dites quoi le matin quand vous
regardez dans le miroir je me dis bon
encore une petite commence on a qu'à se
dire qu'on a de la chance vous auriez
aimé ressembler à qui quand vous étiez
petit petit
Spider-Man qu'elle insulte que vous avez
le plus mal
attendez que j'espère
ça fait un petit moment
oh non peut-être que c'est les trucs là
que je lis en ce moment dans la presse
quand il y a des gens qui comprennent
pas le film ça m'énerve moi j'ai lu que
des bons papiers sur le film il y a eu
un truc qui m'a énervé les gens disent
il y a un mec qui a écrit que le film
était cheap et je l'ai pris pour moi
quand avez-vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois donc Blueberry dans une scène mais
pour le rôle ah mais sinon en vrai
si vous aviez une baguette magique
un peu moins d'ego
quel est le péché qui vous tente le plus
la luxure avec ta femme
qui avez-vous le plus envie des pâtes
déjà moi
quelle est la dernière chose que vous
faites le soir avant de vous coucher une
petite branlette
même lui tu vois donc finalement c'est
très rassurant pour le reste de
l'humanité ça
les gens ne comprennent mal chez eux le
mec il est avec Monica Bellucci il y a
un problème énorme Vincent que
pourriez-vous dire de plus négatif sur
vous il vient de le faire trop tard
c'est vrai bonne réponse
qu'est-ce que je pourrais dire de plus
négatif sur moi
là tout de suite tu es vraiment un chien
dans Blueberry
si votre vie était à refaire vous
changeriez quoi
pour le moment pas grand chose
quand on voit vos films de votre femme
c'est vrai qu'on se dit dans le fond il
y a pas que ça ouais
il y a bien des points faibles il y a
des trucs qui vont pas rire
Vincent que nous ne sachions pas alors
justement restons là
vous avez menti durant cette interview
bien sûr que non
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu